WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. I don't know if you've had this experience. We've all heard all the speeches about how we're going to war, how the war is going to take years. And it's hard to understand what we're in for. Is it going to be attacks and counterattacks, and American cities poisoned with chemical weapons? Or are we talking about a war that doesn't touch most of our lives very often at all, an occasional commando raid in some faraway place, a flash of headlines, not much more. Those are very different scenarios. What does it mean if we get into a war?
芝加哥WBEZ和公共广播国际电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我不知道你是否有过这样的经历。我们都听过关于我们要去打仗、战争将持续数年的演讲。我们很难理解我们将要面对什么。是攻击和反击，还是美国城市遭到化学武器毒害？又或者我们谈论的是一场根本不会触及我们大多数人日常生活的战争，只是在某个遥远的地方偶尔进行一次突击突袭，头条新闻闪现一下，仅此而已。这些是截然不同的情景。如果我们卷入一场战争，那意味着什么？
I say if, but of course the President and everybody in a suit in Washington DC is saying there is no if at this point. We're going to war. What does it mean? Our program today tries to address that question in four acts. We have a story sorting out exactly what we know right now, today, about what the coming war will be like. Plus stories about the psychology and life during wartime, and how it is different from life during peacetime. And Scott Carrier talks to Americans who are ready to go and die, and send their children to go and die in this coming war. Stay with us.
我说的是“如果”，但当然，总统和华盛顿特区所有穿西装的人都在说，现在已经没有“如果”了。我们要去打仗。这意味着什么？我们今天的节目试图通过四幕来探讨这个问题。我们有一个故事，梳理了我们在此时此刻、在今天，关于即将到来的战争会是什么样子所了解的一切。此外，还有关于战时心理和生活的故事，以及它与和平时期生活有何不同。斯科特·卡里尔采访了那些准备好要去牺牲，并准备送自己的孩子去这场即将到来的战争中牺牲的美国人。请继续收听。
Act one, The Situation in the Field. So it's been kind of confusing, right? For a few days after the attacks on September 11th, it seemed like we were just on the verge of bombing and retaliation. And we were issuing ultimatums to the Taliban. We were sending aircraft overseas. Now two weeks have gone by, and as our weekend began, nothing had happened. A couple days ago, there were stories on the front page of the New York Times saying essentially that the US still does not have a plan. Does not have a plan, still is not clear about what might be effective.
第一幕，战场态势。所以情况一直有点混乱，对吧？在9月11日袭击发生后的几天里，似乎我们正处于轰炸和报复的边缘。我们向塔利班发出了最后通牒。我们正在向海外派遣飞机。现在两周过去了，周末开始时，什么也没发生。几天前，《纽约时报》头版刊登的文章基本上说，美国仍然没有计划。没有计划，仍然不清楚什么才是有效的。
So to help sort out what exactly we know at this point about the coming war, we are thrilled to welcome Tom Gjelten, an actual NPR correspondent, to our program. He's been covering the story from the Pentagon for National Public Radio. In the past, he's covered wars in Bosnia, Sarajevo, Nicaragua, and El Salvador. He says we know the troops have been moved overseas. We don't know the number, but it's nowhere near what was sent to the Persian Gulf War.
因此，为了帮助梳理我们在此时此刻关于即将到来的战争究竟了解多少，我们非常高兴地欢迎汤姆·耶尔滕，一位真正的NPR记者，来到我们的节目。他一直为国家公共广播电台报道五角大楼的相关新闻。过去，他曾报道过波斯尼亚、萨拉热窝、尼加拉瓜和萨尔瓦多的战争。他说，我们知道部队已经被调往海外。我们不知道具体人数，但远没有波斯湾战争时期派遣的那么多。
And I think we also know that more specialized units, even commando units, Special Forces, are on the ground in Pakistan now. And there are probably American ground forces and air crews in Uzbekistan and Tajikistan.
我认为我们还知道，更多专业部队，甚至是突击队、特种部队，现在已经进入巴基斯坦境内。在乌兹别克斯坦和塔吉克斯坦可能也有美国的地面部队和空勤人员。
14,000 reservists have been called to service?
14000名预备役人员被征召入伍了？
So far. It's like the stories-- it used to be we did a story every time we bombed Iraq. And now we don't do that anymore, because we're bombing Iraq like two or three times a week. I used to do a story here, just in the last couple weeks, every time we had a big mobilization. Now we're getting mobilizations every day, I don't even bother to keep tally anymore. We're above 14,000 now. There were 600 or so yesterday, I didn't even pay any attention to it.
到目前为止是这样。这就像那些报道一样——过去我们每次轰炸伊拉克都会做一个报道。而现在我们不再这样做了，因为我们每周轰炸伊拉克两三次。就在过去几周，每次有大规模动员，我都会在这里做一个报道。现在我们每天都在进行动员，我甚至都懒得再去统计了。我们现在已经超过14000人了。昨天大约有600人，我甚至都没有关注。
And based on what we know so far, what's our best guess as to what kind of war we're going to be facing over the next few months and years?
根据我们目前所知，对于未来几个月和几年里我们将面临什么样的战争，我们最好的猜测是什么？
I think one of the things about this is that it's going to be a drama of several acts. It's going to go on, and each act is going to be completely different from the one that preceded it. We are now in the first act. And the first act is about chasing the bad guys. It's about going after Osama bin Laden, and it's going to be dramatic, because there are going to be these Special Forces, these American commandos, and there's going to be British commandos. And they're going to be going through the mountains and they're going to be going into caves and trying to find the terrorists hiding in caves.
我认为这件事的一点在于，它将是一部几幕剧。它会持续进行，每一幕都将与前一幕完全不同。我们现在正处于第一幕。第一幕是关于追捕坏人。它是关于追捕奥萨马·本·拉登，这将是戏剧性的，因为会有这些特种部队，这些美国突击队，还有英国突击队。他们将穿过山脉，进入洞穴，试图找到躲在洞穴里的恐怖分子。
So that's going to be the first round. But then who knows what the result of that is going to be? Defense Secretary Donald Rumsfeld said the other day something-- he said a couple things that were really remarkable. He said that this is like playing a game of billiards, where you hit the ball, and then you sort of step back and watch what it careens off. And you sort of hope that in the end, the right thing happens. I mean, we're going into this war really without any idea of what the next round is going to be, and how what we do in this round is going to affect what happens in the next round.
所以这将是第一轮。但之后谁知道结果会如何呢？国防部长唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德前几天说了一些话——他说了几件非常了不起的事情。他说这就像打台球，你击球后，退后一步看它弹到哪里。你希望最终会发生正确的事情。我的意思是，我们进入这场战争时，真的不知道下一轮会是什么，我们这一轮所做的事情将如何影响下一轮发生的事情。
And when Pentagon officials talk about these commando units, is there a fear that these kind of limited actions will explode into a broader war? How much do they talk about that? How much of a possibility is that?
当五角大楼官员谈论这些突击队时，是否担心这种有限的行动会演变成更广泛的战争？他们谈论这个有多少？这种可能性有多大？
The people who think about this in strategic terms-- you know in the Pentagon, there are people who have different sort of thinking responsibilities-- and the people who do think about this in strategic terms are very much worried about that, because it's so hard to predict. And we in the United States have drawn this clear distinction between terrorism and Islam. But the truth of it is that I think there are a lot of people in the United States who are worried that any military action is going to be interpreted by people in the Muslim world as an attack on Islam.
那些从战略角度思考这个问题的人——你知道五角大楼里有些人有不同的思考职责——而那些确实从战略角度思考这个问题的人非常担心这一点，因为这太难预测了。我们美国已经划清了恐怖主义和伊斯兰教之间的界限。但事实是，我认为美国有很多担心，任何军事行动都会被穆斯林世界的人解读为对伊斯兰教的攻击。
And I have to say, there are those who worry about a World War III type scenario, where this just gets out of hand and the United States enrages-- there are 1 billion Muslims in the world. And there are people that worry that this will get out of hand, and it will become this sort of global conflagration.
我必须说，有些人担心会出现第三次世界大战式的情景，即事情失控，美国激怒了——世界上有10亿穆斯林。有人担心这会失控，演变成某种全球性的大火灾。
And how likely do you view the possibility that it will become a war between the West and Islam as somebody who's watching this closely?
作为一个密切关注此事的人，你认为它演变成西方与伊斯兰之间战争的可能性有多大？
I feel a lot better about that, Ira, right now than I did a week ago. And I feel confident that it's not going to become that in the short run.
艾拉，我现在对这个感觉比一周前好多了。我有信心它在短期内不会变成那样。
Because of all the alliances the US is being so careful to make with the countries around Afghanistan?
是因为美国正在非常小心地与阿富汗周边国家建立的所有联盟吗？
Yes, because the United States, the people that are directing this campaign are aware of that danger. And they are proceeding very carefully. Let's just hope that that focus stays in place.
是的，因为美国，那些指挥这场战役的人意识到这种危险。他们正在非常谨慎地进行。让我们希望这种专注能保持下去。
The impression from afar, just from those of us just reading the papers and hearing stories on radio and TV, is that there's a lot of really tough rhetoric at the beginning, and since then there's been a very sober and very rational look at the downside to the various actions. And it actually feels like we're proceeding in a very careful way. It's reassuring.
从远处看，仅仅从我们这些读报纸、听广播和电视新闻的人来看，开始时有很多强硬的措辞，但从那时起，对各种行动的负面影响进行了非常冷静和理性的审视。实际上感觉我们正在以非常谨慎的方式行事。这让人放心。
But I have to tell Ira, there's a lot a debate about this.
但我必须告诉你，艾拉，关于这一点有很多争论。
Really?
真的吗？
The story's not over yet. There are people in the government who are arguing that the problem with terrorism is not going to be solved unless the states that are in some way sponsoring it are basically overthrown. I mean, there are people who are arguing that this war should be directed against Iraq. There are people who say Syria should become a target. That debate is not yet resolved. I mean, we're still in round one of this thing, and in round one, it's going to be limited. But people say that this is going to go on for years, and who knows what round two or round three or round four will turn into.
故事还没结束。政府里有人主张，如果不从根本上推翻那些以某种方式资助它的国家，恐怖主义问题就不会得到解决。我的意思是，有人主张这场战争应该针对伊拉克。有人说叙利亚应该成为目标。这场辩论还没有解决。我的意思是，我们仍然处于这件事的第一轮，在第一轮中，它是有限的。但人们说这将会持续数年，谁知道第二轮、第三轮或第四轮会变成什么样。
Tom Gjelten covers the Defense Department for NPR's daily news programs.
汤姆·耶尔滕为NPR的每日新闻节目报道国防部。
Act two, Letters to Home. So if we're going to war, what is it going to be like? Let us remember what it was like. A guy named Andrew Carroll recently started something called the Legacy Project, collecting letters America's wrote home during wartime. He was sent over 50,000 letters and collected them into a book. He says from the Civil War through the World Wars up through Korea and Vietnam, some things are the same.
第二幕，寄给家里的信。所以如果我们去打仗，会是什么样子？让我们记住过去的样子。一个叫安德鲁·卡罗尔的人最近发起了所谓的“遗产计划”，收集美国人在战时寄回家的信件。他收到了超过5万封信，并将它们汇编成书。他说，从内战到世界大战，再到朝鲜战争和越南战争，有些事情是相同的。
In every war, in the beginning you have this sense of urgency, almost the impassioned desire to strike back, to fight, to go overseas. And then gradually, as the young people themselves see what war is truly like, you see an ebbing away of that enthusiasm. And at the end, regardless of the war, even in the so-called noble wars, whether it's the Civil War or World War II, you see a great sense of disgust about what war is, an exhaustion, a fatigue, just a bitterness.
在每一场战争的开始，你都会有一种紧迫感，几乎是一种强烈的反击、战斗、去海外的愿望。然后逐渐地，当年轻人自己看到战争的真实面目时，你会看到那种热情在消退。最后，无论战争如何，即使是在所谓的正义战争中，无论是内战还是二战，你都会看到对战争是什么样子的极度厌恶，一种精疲力竭，一种疲劳，只剩下苦涩。
Let me ask you just to illustrate this idea of how the letters change over time. Can I ask you to read a letter or two that are in your collection in the book, a letter from a man named Sydney Diamond, a lieutenant.
让我请你读一两封你书里收集的信，来说明这种信件随时间变化的观点，一封来自一个名叫悉尼·戴蒙德的中尉的信。
Yeah. I love Sydney Diamond and his fiancee Estelle Spiro. And Sydney would say, he'd say later after he met Estelle that-- I think they were 14 or 16 at the time-- that the second time he walked her home, he knew he'd marry her. And they're just a wonderful couple. And Sydney was gung ho about going off to war. He was a very smart young man, and he volunteered for what would be a very dangerous division.
好的。我爱悉尼·戴蒙德和他的未婚妻埃斯特尔·斯皮罗。悉尼曾说，他在见到埃斯特尔后——我想他们当时分别是14岁或16岁——第二次送她回家时，就知道自己会娶她。他们是一对非常棒的情侣。悉尼非常热衷于去打仗。他是个非常聪明的年轻人，自愿加入了一个非常危险的师。
And he was a very funny guy, and he wrote these very humorous letters to Estelle in the beginning of the war, and he knew that she was upset with him for going off to fight.
他是个很有趣的人，在战争初期他给埃斯特尔写了这些非常幽默的信，而且他知道她因为他要去打仗而对他感到难过。
And let's start with a letter that he writes on August 17th. This is still when he's lively and funny and enthusiastic about things. He writes it in the form of a sort of a mock war memo.
让我们从他8月17日写的一封信开始。这时他还很活泼、有趣，对事情充满热情。他以某种模拟战争备忘录的形式写了这封信。
Exactly. It's a tongue in cheek memo. And so it's subject, Ms. Estelle Spiro, to the world. Number one, on several occasions there's been questions posed as the rank and authority in the Diamond combat team.
没错。这是一个半开玩笑的备忘录。主题是：致埃斯特尔·斯皮罗小姐，致全世界。第一，曾多次有人对戴蒙德作战队的等级和权威提出疑问。
The Diamond combat team is similarly like him and her?
戴蒙德作战队是指他和她吗？
Yeah, they're a couple.
是的，他们是一对。
Him and her? Them as a couple?
他和她？他们作为一对情侣？
Yeah, the two of them together. Also some people have asked about who is most beautiful. The following paragraphs supersede any previous bulletins on these matters. Number two, commander of the organization will be Miss Estelle, who upon assuming command, will be responsible for the maintenance of discipline amongst her subordinates, in particular Lieutenant Diamond. Ms. Estelle will be charged with the morale and well being of this officer.
是的，他们两个人在一起。另外，有些人问谁最漂亮。以下段落取代之前关于这些事项的所有公告。第二，该组织的指挥官将是埃斯特尔小姐，她在上任后将负责对其下属，特别是戴蒙德中尉保持纪律。埃斯特尔小姐将负责这位军官的士气和幸福。
Number three, careful studies the photograph to indicate that the CO is by far the most proportioned, most attractive of all models heretofore presented. The mark IAI reveals the following assets: A, irresistible lips; B, clear vision; C, black, long eyelashes; D, long, flowing hair, slightly kinky; E, eyebrows, parenthetically note. One must be careful of these. When they are raised, duck for cover; F, nose, very adaptable for biting, also very pretty; G, ears, be careful of these. They're usually hidden and well camouflaged. If you get too close, you'll be caught by booby trap M-2 earring.
第三，仔细研究照片表明，指挥官是迄今为止所有展示的模特中最匀称、最迷人的。IAI标记显示出以下资产：A，无法抗拒的嘴唇；B，清晰的视力；C，黑色长睫毛；D，长而飘逸的头发，有点卷曲；E，眉毛，括号注。必须小心这些。当它们竖起来时，赶快躲起来；F，鼻子，非常适合咬，也非常漂亮；G，耳朵，小心这些。它们通常被隐藏和伪装得很好。如果你靠得太近，你会被M-2耳环诱杀装置抓住。
Four, we recommend that this equipment be requisitioned for Lieutenant Diamond's organization, and they get married at the earliest possible moment. Despite Lieutenant Diamond's demonstrated lack of skill in handling this equipment, we feel he is sufficiently interested to study and learn this instrument, its nomenclature, its functions, its use, its quirks and needs. He will be responsible for the care of this instrument. General E. Motors. So this just to give you a sense of his style, his whimsy and--.
第四，我们建议为戴蒙德中尉的组织征用这些装备，并让他们尽快结婚。尽管戴蒙德中尉在操作这些装备方面表现出缺乏技巧，但我们认为他有足够的兴趣去学习和了解这种仪器、它的命名法、它的功能、它的用途、它的怪癖和需求。他将负责照顾这种仪器。通用汽车将军。所以这只是为了让你感受一下他的风格、他的奇思妙想以及——。
He loves that girl, man.
伙计，他很爱那个女孩。
He loves her. And there are many other letters like this that are very funny in nature. But as the War goes on-- he's over in the Pacific-- you begin to see the change. And a later letter he writes just a few months later, this is Christmas day, 1944.
他爱她。还有许多其他像这样本质上非常有趣的信件。但随着战争的进行——他在太平洋那边——你开始看到变化。几个月后他写的一封后来的信，这是1944年的圣诞节。
Now this is just four months after the letter where he describes the Diamond combat team.
这距离他描述戴蒙德作战队的那封信只有四个月。
Exactly.
没错。
And he's been in combat since?
从那以后他一直都在战斗中？
Correct. And he's seen when they've gone to some of the islands in the Pacific, they've seen the atrocities committed by the Japanese onto the natives. And this is a letter he writes on Christmas day, and his spirits really couldn't be lower.
正确。他看到了当他们到达太平洋的一些岛屿时，他们看到了日本人对当地人犯下的暴行。这是他在圣诞节写的一封信，他的情绪真的跌到了谷底。
Darling, it is difficult at present to be the cold, the practical. Even more it is hard to be humorous or laugh, to joke. I cannot say where we are, what we are doing, what we will do. There's been so much between us unsaid and undone, so much of our lives missed. I would like to fill the air with plans, dreams, hopes, but Estelle, all there is is a choking in the chest. Every once in a while, a guy gets himself overcome by despair. Despondency overwhelms him.
亲爱的，目前很难变得冷酷、务实。更难的是变得幽默、欢笑、开玩笑。我不能说我们在哪里，在做什么，我们将要做什么。我们之间有太多未说出口、未做过的事，错过了太多生活。我本想用计划、梦想、希望填满空气，但埃斯特尔，我只有胸口的窒息感。每隔一段时间，一个人就会被绝望所淹没。沮丧压倒了他。
it is so long, so very long. I love you Darling. Whatever happens, be happy. That's my only request. Get everything we would have liked, fill your life, or only keep my little niche open, so if I ever get home, I'll know there's one place waiting for me, my corner of the world. Let it be a small alcove in your heart. Put a comfortable chair there and always keep a warm fire glowing, because if I come home in any recognizable form, I'll head directly for that chair. That's where I belong. That's my home with you. Your Sid.
时间太长了，太长了。我爱你，亲爱的。无论发生什么，要快乐。这是我唯一的请求。去实现我们想要的一切，充实你的生活，或者只为我留一个小小的角落，如果我能回家，我会知道有一个地方在等我，我的世界角落。让它成为你心中一个小小的壁龛吧。放一把舒服的椅子，永远让温暖的火光照耀，因为如果我能以任何可辨认的形式回家，我会径直走向那把椅子。那是属于我的地方。那是和你在一起的家。你的悉尼。
Andrew Carroll, who assembled the book War Letters. Just four months after Sid Diamond wrote that letter, his fiancee Estelle Spiro got word that he'd been shot and killed in Manila. The last time she'd seen him was nearly two years before that. Estelle Spiro is now Estelle Lynch, married with two children and two grandchildren, living in Queens, New York. We caught her up, and she was gracious enough to talk with us as a kind of memorial to Sid. That Sid was proud to sign up to fight, she said, so that war was a ridiculous way for people to try to solve disputes. She has a lot of letters from him.
安德鲁·卡罗尔，他汇编了《战争书信》一书。在悉尼·戴蒙德写下那封信仅四个月后，他的未婚妻埃斯特尔·斯皮罗就收到了他在马尼拉被枪杀的消息。她最后一次见他是在那之前的近两年。埃斯特尔·斯皮罗现在叫埃斯特尔·林奇，已婚，有两个孩子和两个孙子，住在纽约皇后区。我们找到了她，她很客气地和我们交谈，作为对悉尼的一种纪念。她说，悉尼为能参战而感到自豪，所以战争是人们试图解决争端的一种荒谬方式。她有很多他的信。
I have 520 odd from World War II, and about another 100 from three years before that.
我有520多封二战时期的信，还有在大约三年之前写的另外100封。
Do you read these letters very often at all?
你经常读这些信吗？
No, actually I didn't. I was afraid to read them until I got interested in the Legacy Project. And then I read all of them, all of them. Every night I'd read a batch.
不，其实没有。在我对“遗产计划”感兴趣之前，我不敢读它们。然后我读了所有的信，全部。每天晚上我都会读一批。
And what was that like?
那是什么感觉？
Terrible.
太可怕了。
I would imagine that reading these letters must take the half century since they passed and just make it seem like nothing. It must seem like it happened yesterday.
我想读这些信一定让过去半个世纪的时间消逝了，让它看起来就像什么都没发生过一样。感觉就像昨天才发生的一样。
That's exactly right. It's as though it just happened.
完全正确。就好像刚刚发生的一样。
Were you seeing things in them now reading them that you don't think that you saw at the time?
你现在读它们的时候，有没有看到当时没有看到的东西？
Well, the yearning for me is just overwhelming. I guess I have seen a couple of places where he expresses regret at hurting me, which of course he felt all along. But I see it very vividly now.
嗯，对我的思念简直让人无法承受。我想我看到了几个地方，他表达了对伤害我的遗憾，当然他一直都有这种感觉。但我现在看得非常清楚。
Regretted hurting you by going?
后悔因为离开而伤害了你？
Yes. And I see expressions like, if I ever come back. Although at the beginning at least, in the first year or so, he always said, I'm coming back, I'm coming back. And then later, I see, if I ever get back.
是的。我看到了像“如果我能回来”这样的表达。虽然至少在开始时，在第一年左右，他总是说，“我会回来的，我会回来的。”然后后来，我看到的是，“如果我能回来”。
You didn't want him to enlist, and he did enlist. How do you feel about that? What do you think about that when you read these letters?
你不想让他入伍，但他还是入伍了。你对此有何感想？当你读这些信时，你对此有什么看法？
Well, I was very much against it when he went. I still wish he hadn't, and it's not because I didn't believe in what we like to call The Good War. But I thought that he should have waited until he was drafted. He was finishing his third year as an engineering student, and I felt he would have had many more options open to him. He would not have ended up fighting with the infantry, which he did as a member of the chemical warfare service. And I think he'd have had a much better chance of surviving, because I can see from his friends and from my friends, that they went about a year later than he did.
嗯，他去的时候我非常反对。我仍然希望他没有去，并不是因为我不相信我们所谓的“正义战争”。但我认为他应该等到被征召。他当时快要完成作为工程系学生的第三年学业，我觉得他会有更多的选择。他本不会去和步兵一起战斗，而他是化学战部队的成员。我认为他本会有更好的生存机会，因为从他的朋友和我的朋友那里可以看出，他们比他晚了一年左右才去。
So I can appreciate the fact that he was acting according to principle, and his ideals, and felt it was important to go. But I still wish he hadn't.
所以我可以理解他是在根据原则和理想行事，觉得去战斗很重要。但我仍然希望他没有去。
Do you feel like he was able to hold onto his idealism?
你觉得他能够坚持他的理想主义吗？
At maybe two or three points, he says no more crusades.
在两三个地方，他说不再有十字军东征了。
When he says no more crusades, he means no more crusades for him?
当他说不再有十字军东征时，他是指对他自己来说不再有十字军东征吗？
No more crusades for him. And then in some other-- I think one of the letters that's in the book, I'm not sure-- he says all you've got in me is a person of blah, blah, blah, blah, and ideals. And when this is over, you won't have any ideals to contend with.
对他来说不再有。然后在其他地方——我想书里有一封信，我不确定——他说你在我身上看到的只有某种东西和理想。当这一切结束时，你将不会有任何理想可以去争论了。
As the war went on, he felt less and less idealistic about it, and less and less inclined to be part of a crusade. What do you think about that?
随着战争的进行，他觉得对它的理想主义越来越少，越来越不愿意参加十字军东征。你对此怎么看？
Well, again, I have mixed feelings, because I was happy in some degree to feel that he was agreeing that perhaps he shouldn't have gone when he did. On the other hand, I would not have wanted him to suffer by giving up his ideals. There he was, fighting. I think it was better for him to feel that he was fighting for something worthwhile. I can't say more than that.
嗯，我又有复杂的感觉，因为在某种程度上我很高兴觉得他同意也许他不应该在他去的时候就去。另一方面，我不希望他因为放弃理想而受苦。他当时在那里战斗。我想对他来说，觉得自己在为值得的事情战斗更好。我不能说更多了。
Yeah. When you look at the way people are reacting to the idea of going to war again, do you feel like people are embracing it with an eagerness that a generation that lived through a massive war can't, or wouldn't?
是的。当你看到人们对再次参战的想法的反应时，你觉得人们是否以一种经历过大规模战争的一代人所不能或不会有的热情来拥抱它？
As a matter of fact, I guess a day or two after this happened, we went to a neighborhood restaurant for dinner. We were the only people there. The waiter was a very young chap, 21 I guess, Romanian, who had been in this country since he was 11 or 12 I think. And he said, I love this country. I am ready to go to war. And I said, young man, don't be so ready to go to war. If they need you, they'll come and get you. You don't have to put yourself out there. And of course I was thinking of Sid.
事实上，我想在事情发生后的一两天，我们去了一家社区餐厅吃晚饭。我们是那里仅有的人。服务员是一个非常年轻的小伙子，我想21岁，罗马尼亚人，从11或12岁起就在这个国家了。他说：“我爱这个国家。我准备好去打仗了。”我说：“年轻人，不要那么准备去打仗。如果他们需要你，他们会来找你的。你不必把自己置身于危险之中。”当然，我当时想到的是悉尼。
A. E. Housman, in one of his poems, said, too full already is the grave of fellows who were good and brave, and died because they were.
A.E.豪斯曼在其中一首诗中说，坟墓里已经挤满了那些善良勇敢的人，他们因为善良勇敢而死。
Estelle Lynch. When we were done with our interview, I asked her is she'd like to read one of Sid's letters. The question caught her by surprise. She hadn't chose one in advance, so she just opened to a letter at random. It was writing in New Caledonia in 1943, the month Sid left the US.
埃斯特尔·林奇。当我们采访结束时，我问她是否想读一封悉尼的信。这个问题让她感到惊讶。她没有提前选好，所以她只是随机打开了一封信。这是1943年悉尼离开美国那个月在新喀里多尼亚写的。
I'm located in a large island in the Southwest Pacific. The language spoken on the island is French. Don't think I haven't been brushing up on the little French I once knew. An incident which occurred in town. I struck up a conversation with one of the girl's taking care of a lemonade stand. It was all in French, mind you. I was doing quite well too. She caught sight of your ring, and immediately asked me if I was married. I told her I was engaged, and promptly produced your picture.
我位于西南太平洋的一个大岛上。岛上说的语言是法语。别以为我没有温习我曾经知道的那点法语。镇上发生了一件事。我和一个在柠檬水摊前卖东西的女孩搭讪了。都是用法语，请注意。我做得也相当不错。她看到了你的戒指，立刻问我是不是结婚了。我告诉她我订婚了，并立即拿出了你的照片。
Very pretty, she exclaimed. How come all American boys are married or engaged to pretty girls? All I could do was shrug my shoulders. Then I had some ice cream, very watery but good. I feel quite elated at the opportunity to use some French. The difficulty is the few opportunities one has for visiting. My striker, or orderly, knows you. Or should I say your picture by now. As soon as I pulled it out, he remarked, you want it here facing you when you write letters? And that's where you are, a bit in the shadows but still present.
“真漂亮，”她惊叹道。“为什么所有美国男孩都和漂亮女孩结婚或订婚？”我只能耸耸肩。然后我吃了一些冰淇淋，水汪汪的但很好吃。我有机会说法语感到非常兴奋。困难的是很少有机会去访问。我的勤务兵认识你。或者我应该说他现在认识你的照片了。我一拿出来，他就说：“你写信时想让它面对着你吗？”你就是那样，有点在阴影中，但依然存在。
Darling, remember always, I love you. Your Sid.
亲爱的，永远记住，我爱你。你的悉尼。
Estelle Lynch.
埃斯特尔·林奇。
[MUSIC - "REMEMBER PEARL HARBOR" BY SAMMY KAYE AND HIS ORCHESTRA WITH THE GLEE CLUB]
[音乐 - 萨米·凯和他的管弦乐队演唱《记住珍珠港》]
Act Three, What Peacetime Forgets About Wartime. At a weekly paper here in Chicago a few years back, The Chicago Reader , a writer named Lee Sandlin wrote a story about what it is that makes wartime different. About the particular psychology of being at war. It was a massive historical article, exhaustively researched. He was interested partly in World War II and why it had been forgotten, and in what it was that had been forgotten. Here's an excerpt. Lee Sandlin's in China, so it was read for us by Matt Malloy.
第三幕，和平时期遗忘了战时的什么。几年前在芝加哥的一份周报《芝加哥读者》上，一位名叫李·桑德林的作家写了一篇关于什么让战时与众不同的文章。关于处于战争状态的特殊心理。这是一篇详尽的历史文章，经过了详尽的研究。他部分对二战以及为什么它被遗忘感兴趣，以及被遗忘的是什么。这里有一个摘录。李·桑德林人在中国，所以由马特·马洛伊为我们朗读。
Back when the forest still stretched in an unbroken expanse from Scandinavia to the Urals, the Vikings who inhabited its northernmost reaches wrote down their own stories about war. Their legends may have been garish fantasies, cursed rings and enchanted gold and dragons slayers. But when they wrote about battle, they were unsparingly exact. Their sagas still offer the subtlest and most rigorous accounts of the unique psychology of combat.
早在森林从斯堪的纳维亚半岛一直延伸到乌拉尔山脉的时候，居住在最北端的维京人就写下了他们自己的战争故事。他们的传说可能是荒诞的幻想，被诅咒的戒指、被施了魔法的黄金和屠龙者。但当他们写到战斗时，他们是非常严谨的。他们的传奇至今仍提供了关于战斗独特心理的最微妙、最严谨的记录。
They knew that the experience of being on a battlefield is fundamentally different from everything else in life. It simply can't be described with ordinary words, so they devised a specialized vocabulary to handle it. Some of their terms will do perfectly well for a World War fought 1,000 years later. The Vikings knew, for instance, that prolonged exposure to combat can goad some men into a state of uncontrolled psychic fury. They might be the most placid men in the world in peacetime, but on the battlefield, they begin to act with the most inexplicable and gratuitous cruelty.
他们知道，身处战场的经历与生活中其他一切根本不同。它根本无法用普通的语言来描述，所以他们设计了一种专门的词汇来处理它。他们的一些术语对于1000年后发生的世界大战非常适用。例如，维京人知道，长时间接触战斗会激怒一些人进入一种无法控制的精神狂暴状态。他们可能在平时是世界上最温和的人，但在战场上，他们开始以最莫名其妙和无缘无故的残忍行事。
They become convinced that they're invincible, above all rules and restraints, literally transformed into superman and werewolves. The Vikings called such men berserkers. World War II was filled with instances of ordinary soldiers giving into berserker behavior. In battle after battle, soldiers on all sides are observed killing wantonly and indiscriminately, defying all orders to stop, in a kind of collective blood rage. They were found in every army, even among those that emphasize discipline and humane conduct.
他们确信自己是不可战胜的，凌驾于所有规则和限制之上，简直变成了超人和狼人。维京人把这样的人称为“狂战士”。二战中充满了普通士兵屈服于狂战士行为的例子。在一场又一场的战斗中，各方的士兵被观察到在进行一种集体血腥狂暴中，肆无忌惮地、不分青红皂白地杀戮，无视所有停止的命令。他们在每一支军队中都能找到，即使是在那些强调纪律和人道行为的军队中。
American Marines in the Pacific became notorious for their berserker mentality, particularly their profound lack of interest in taking prisoners. In his memoir, a Marine named Eugene Sledge describes once seeing another Marine in a classic berserker state urinating into the open mouth of a dead Japanese soldier.
太平洋上的美国海军陆战队因其狂战士心态而臭名昭著，特别是他们对抓俘虏深感无趣。在一篇回忆录中，一名叫尤金·斯莱奇的海军陆战队员描述了有一次看到另一名海军陆战队员处于典型的狂战士状态，对着一名死去的日本士兵张开的嘴里小便。
Another viking term was fey. People now understand it to mean effeminate. Previously it meant odd, and before that, uncanny, fairy like. That was back when Fairyland was the most sinister place people could imagine. The old Norse word meant doomed. It was used to refer to an eerie mood that would come over people in battle, a kind of transcendent despair. The state was described vividly by an American reporter, Tom Lee, in the midst of the desperate Battle of Peleliu in the South Pacific.
另一个维京术语是“fey”。人们现在把它理解为女性化。以前它意味着奇怪，再早之前，神秘，像仙女。那是当仙境还是人们能想象的最险恶的地方的时候。这个古老的北欧词意味着注定。它被用来指代战斗中人们会产生的一种怪异情绪，一种超凡的绝望。这种状态被美国记者汤姆·李在南太平洋贝里琉岛惨烈的战斗中生动地描述过。
He felt something inside of himself, some instinctive psychic urge to keep himself alive, finally collapse at the site of one more dead soldier in the ruins of a tropical jungle. Lee wrote, he seemed so quiet and empty, and passed all the small things a man could love or hate. I suddenly knew I no longer had to defend my beating heart against the stillness of death. There was no defense. There was no defense, that's fey.
他感觉到内心深处，某种本能的精神冲动想要保持活下去，最终在热带丛林的废墟中看到又一名死去的士兵时崩溃了。李写道，他看起来是那么安静、空虚，超越了一个男人可以爱或恨的所有小事。我突然知道我不再需要保护我跳动的心脏免受死亡的静谧。没有防御。没有防御，这就是“fey”。
People go through battle willing the bullet to miss, the shelling to stop, the heart to go on beating. And then they feel something in their soul surrender, and they give into everything they've been most afraid of. It's like a glimpse of eternity. Whether the battle is lost or won, it will never end. It has wholly taken over the soul. Sometimes men say afterward that the most terrifying moment of any battle is seeing a fey look on the faces of the soldiers standing next to them.
人们经历战斗，祈求子弹落空，炮击停止，心脏继续跳动。然后他们感到灵魂中的某种东西投降了，他们屈服于他们最恐惧的一切。这就像是对永恒的一瞥。无论战斗是输是赢，它永远不会结束。它已经完全占据了灵魂。有时事后人们会说，任何战斗中最可怕的时刻就是看到身边士兵脸上的“fey”表情。
Feyness might also explain the deepest mystery of the war, why the surrender everybody expected never came. The Germans and Japanese refused to surrender, even though they knew the war was lost. It's possible to quibble about the exact point at which the war was decided, Midway, Stalingrad, Filles, Okinawa. But by some unmistakable point, the autumn of 1942 at the latest, they should have understood that they'd been wrong, and that their prospects for long term victory were zeroing out.
“feyness”可能也解释了战争中最大的谜团，为什么每个人预期的投降从未到来。德国人和日本人拒绝投降，即使他们知道战争已经失败。可以争论战争决定性点的确切位置，中途岛、斯大林格勒、法莱斯、冲绳。但在某些无可辩驳的点上，最迟在1942年秋天，他们本应明白自己错了，他们长期获胜的前景正在归零。
They still had the economic and military strength to sustain their armies in the field indefinitely. But by any rational calculation of the odds, they should have begun hinting through backwater diplomatic channels that they were willing to negotiate a ceasefire. Neither Germany nor Japan ever did so. Not until the last days of the war did either government even consider a negotiated settlement, not until they had absolutely nothing left to negotiate with.
他们仍然有经济和军事实力来无限期地维持他们在战场上的军队。但根据任何理性的胜算计算，他们本应开始通过偏僻的外交渠道暗示他们愿意谈判停火。德国和日本从未这样做过。直到战争的最后几天，两国政府甚至都没有考虑过谈判解决，直到他们绝对没有什么可以谈判的了。
But then that's the point. A rational calculation of the odds is a calculation by the logic of peace. War has a different logic. A kind of vast feyness can infect a military bureaucracy when it's losing a war, a collective slippage at the sense of objective truth in the face of approaching disaster. In the later years of World War II, the bureaucracies of the Axis behind the lines gradually retreated into a dreamy paper war, where they were on the brink of a triumphant reversal of fortune.
但这正是重点所在。对胜算的理性计算是和平逻辑下的计算。战争有不同的逻辑。当军事官僚机构在输掉战争时，一种巨大的“feyness”会感染它，在面对即将到来的灾难时，对客观真理的集体滑坡。在二战的后期，轴心国后方的官僚机构逐渐退缩到一场梦幻般的纸面战争中，在那里他们处于取得胜利反转的边缘。
Not everybody succumbed to these fantasies. But those who understood how hopeless the situation really was also knew that defeat would mean accountability. And they had a reasonably good idea of what would happen to them if they were ever forced to answer for what they'd done. This is the dreadful logic that comes to control a lot of wars. The American Civil War is another example.
并非所有人都屈服于这些幻想。但那些明白局势实际上有多绝望的人也知道，失败将意味着问责。他们相当清楚，如果他们被迫为所作所为负责，他们会发生什么。这就是控制许多战争的可怕逻辑。美国内战是另一个例子。
The losers prolong their agony as much as possible, because they're convinced the alternative is worse. Meanwhile, the winners, who might earlier have accepted a compromised peace, become so maddened by the refusal of their enemies to stop fighting that they see no reason to settle for anything less than absolute victory. In this sense, the later course of World War II was typical. It kept on escalating, no matter what the strategic situation was, and it grew progressively more violent and uncontrollable long after the outcome was a foregone conclusion. The difference was that no other war had ever had such deep reserves of violence to draw upon.
失败者尽可能地延长他们的痛苦，因为他们确信替代方案更糟。与此同时，早先可能接受妥协和平的胜利者，对敌人拒绝停止战斗而变得如此愤怒，以至于他们认为没有理由只满足于绝对胜利以外的任何事情。从这个意义上说，二战后期的进程是典型的。它一直在升级，无论战略局势如何，而且在结果早已成定局后，它变得越来越暴力和不可控。不同之处在于，没有其他战争曾经拥有如此深厚的暴力储备可供利用。
The Vikings would have understood all this. They didn't have a word for the prolongation of war long past any rational goal. They just knew that's what always happened. It's the subject of their longest and greatest saga, the Brennu-Njals Saga, or the Saga of Njal Burned Alive. The saga describes a trivial feud in back country Iceland that keeps escalating for reasons nobody can understand or resolve, until it engulfs the whole of Northern Europe. Provocation after fresh provocation, peace conference after failed peace conference, It has its own momentum like a hurricane of carnage.
维京人会理解这一切。他们没有一个词来形容战争远远超过任何理性目标。他们只知道那是总是发生的事情。这是他们最长、最伟大的传奇的主题，《尼亚尔传奇》，或《被活活烧死的尼亚尔的传奇》。该传奇描述了冰岛农村一场微不足道的争斗，出于没人能理解或解决的原因不断升级，直到它席卷了整个北欧。一次又一次的挑衅，一次又一次失败的和平会议，它有自己的动力，就像一场屠杀的飓风。
For the Vikings, this was the essence of war. It's a mystery that comes out of nowhere and grows for reasons nobody can control, until it shakes the whole world apart.
对于维京人来说，这就是战争的本质。这是一个不知从何而来的谜团，出于没人能控制的原因而增长，直到它把整个世界撕成碎片。
This was the course of World War II from the Fall of 1944 on. After the Allies at last acknowledged that, despite the decisive victories of the previous summer, the Axis was never going to surrender. That was when the Allies changed their strategy. They set out to make an Axis surrender irrelevant. From that winter into the next spring, the civilians of Germany and Japan were helpless before a new Allied campaign of systematic aerial bombardment. The air forces and air defense systems of the Axis were in ruins by then. Allied planes flew where they pleased, day or night, 500 at a time, then 1,000 at a time, indiscriminately dumping avalanches of bombs on every city and town in Axis territory that had a military installation, or a railroad yard, or a factory.
这就是二战从1944年秋天开始的进程。在盟军最终承认，尽管前一个夏天取得了决定性胜利，但轴心国永远不会投降之后。那就是盟军改变战略的时候。他们开始让轴心国投降变得无关紧要。从那个冬天到第二年春天，德国和日本的平民在一场新的盟军系统性空中轰炸战役面前束手无策。当时轴心国的空军和防空系统已成废墟。盟军飞机随心所欲地飞行，日夜不停，一次500架，然后是一次1000架，不分青红皂白地向轴心国境内所有设有军事设施、铁路调车场或工厂的城市和城镇倾泻雪崩般的炸弹。
There was no precedent, even in this war, for the destruction on so ferociously a scale. It was the largest berserker rage in history. The Allies routinely dropped incendiary bombs in such great numbers that they created firestorms in cities throughout the Axis countries. These weren't simply large fires. A true firestorm is a freak event, where a large central core of flame heats up explosively to more than 1,500 degrees, and everything within it goes up by spontaneous combustion. Buildings erupt, the water boils out of rivers and canals, the asphalt and the pavement ignites. Immense intake vortices spring up around the core and begin sucking in oxygen from the surrounding atmosphere at hurricane speeds.
即使在这场战争中，也没有如此凶猛规模破坏的先例。这是历史上最大的狂战士狂暴。盟军经常投下数量如此巨大的燃烧弹，以至于他们在整个轴心国国家的城市中引发了火风暴。这些不仅仅是大火。真正的火风暴是一种反常事件，一个巨大的中心火焰核心爆炸性地加热到超过1500度，其中的一切都会自燃。建筑物喷发，水从河流和运河中沸腾，沥青和路面着火。巨大的进气涡流在核心周围涌现，并开始以飓风的速度从周围的大气中吸入氧气。
The Allied raids reduced cities in minutes to miles of smoking debris. Hundreds of thousands of people were killed, about 20% of them children. Tens of thousands suffocated, because in the area around a firestorm, there's no oxygen left to breathe.
盟军的袭击在几分钟内将城市夷为数英里的冒烟废墟。成千上万的人被杀，其中约20%是儿童。数万人窒息而死，因为在火风暴周围的区域，没有氧气可以呼吸了。
Out of idle curiosity, I've been asking friends, people my age and younger, what they know about war. War stories they've heard from their families, facts they've learned in school, stray images that may have stuck with them from old TV documentaries. I wasn't interested in the fine points of strategy, but the key events, the biggest moments, the things people at the time had thought would live on as long as there was anybody around to remember the past. To give everybody a big enough target, I asked about World War II. I figured people had to know the basics. World War II isn't exactly easy to miss. It was the largest war ever fought, the largest single event in history.
出于闲暇的好奇心，我一直在问朋友们，我这个年纪和更年轻的人，他们对战争了解多少。他们从家人那里听到的战争故事，在学校学到的事实，从老电视纪录片中可能留在他们脑海里的零星画面。我感兴趣的不是战略的精细之处，而是关键事件、最大的时刻，当时人们认为只要还有人记得过去，这些时刻就会长存。为了给每个人一个足够大的目标，我问的是二战。我想人们应该了解基础知识。二战并不容易被忽略。这是有史以来规模最大的战争，也是历史上最大的单一事件。
So what are the people I ask know about the war? Nobody could tell me the first thing about it. Once they got past who won, they almost drew a blank. All they knew were those big, totemic names, Pearl Harbor, D-Day, Auschwitz, Hiroshima. The rest was gone. Kasserine, Leyte Gulf, Corregidor, Filles, the Ardans didn't provoke a glimmer of recognition. They might as well have been off ramps on some exotic interstate.
那么我问的人对这场战争了解多少呢？没人能告诉我关于它的第一件事。一旦他们谈论谁赢了，他们几乎是一片空白。他们所知道的只是那些巨大的、图腾般的名字，珍珠港、诺曼底登陆、奥斯威辛、广岛。其余的都消失了。卡塞林、莱特湾、科雷希多、法莱斯、阿登都没能引起一丝共鸣。它们就像在某个异国州际公路上的出口坡道一样。
What had happened, for instance, at one of the war's biggest battles, the Battle of Midway? It was in the Pacific. There was something about aircraft carriers. Wasn't there a movie about it? A couple of people were even surprised to hear that Midway airport in Chicago was named after the battle, though they'd walk past the ugly commemorative sculpture in the concourse so many times. All in all, this was a dispiriting exercise. The astonishing events of that morning at Midway, the quote, "fatal five minutes" on which the War and the fate of the world had hung, had been reduced to a plaque nobody reads at an airport with a vaguely puzzling name midway between Chicago and nowhere at all.
例如，在战争中最大的战斗之一，中途岛战役中发生了什么？它在太平洋。关于航空母舰有一些事情。不是有一部关于它的电影吗？有几个人甚至很惊讶地听说芝加哥的中途岛机场是以这场战役命名的，尽管他们多次走过候机大厅里那座丑陋的纪念雕塑。总而言之，这是一次令人沮丧的练习。中途岛那天早晨发生的惊人事件，那个战争和世界命运所悬系的“致命五分钟”，被归结为机场里没人阅读的一块牌匾，机场的名字在中途岛与芝加哥之间，去向不明。
Is it that the War was 50 years ago, and nobody cares anymore about what happened in the past? Maybe so. But I think what my little survey really demonstrates is how vast the gap is between the experience of war and the experience of peace. And there's another and simpler reason the war has been forgotten. People wanted to forget it. It had gone on for so many years, had destroyed so much, had killed so many. Most US casualties were in the final year of fighting. When it came to an end, people were glad to be rid of everything about it.
是因为战争是50年前的事了，没人再关心过去发生的事了吗？也许是这样。但我认为我的小调查真正证明的是，战争经历与和平经历之间的差距有多大。战争被遗忘还有另一个更简单的原因。人们想忘记它。它持续了这么多年，摧毁了这么多，杀死了这么多。大多数美国伤亡是在最后一年战斗中发生的。当它结束时，人们很高兴摆脱关于它的一切。
That was what surprised commentators about the public reaction in America and Europe when the news broke that Germany and then Japan had at last surrendered. In the wild celebrations that followed, nobody crowed, our enemies are destroyed. Nobody even yelled, we've won. What they all said instead was, the war is over. That was the message that flashed around the world in the summer of 1945, the war is over. The war is over.
当德国和日本最终投降的消息传出时，这让评论员对美国和公众的反应感到惊讶。随后的狂欢中，没人欢呼“我们的敌人被消灭了”。甚至没人喊“我们赢了”。他们所有人说的是，“战争结束了”。这就是1945年夏天传遍世界的信息，“战争结束了”。战争结束了。
Matt Malloy reading from an article by Lee Sandlin that first appeared in The Chicago Reader in March, 1997. Coming up, soccer moms and Sioux warriors in agreement and ready to fight. In a minute, from Public Radio International and WBEZ Chicago, when our program continues.
马特·马洛伊朗读李·桑德林的一篇文章，该文章首次发表于1997年3月的《芝加哥读者》。接下来，足球妈妈和苏族战士达成共识并准备战斗。一分钟后，来自公共广播国际电台和芝加哥WBEZ，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, the coming war and what are we to make of it. We've arrived at act four of our program. Act four, Are You Ready?
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，即将到来的战争以及我们该如何看待它。我们已经到了节目的第四幕。第四幕，你准备好了吗？
Over the last week, Scott Carrier drove 2,000 miles across the country, from his home in Salt Lake City up north and east till he arrived here in Chicago, talking to people about the coming war. If it's part of the American character to be profoundly skeptical, and another part to be boldly patriotic, he found both tendencies, often in the very same person.
在过去的一周里，斯科特·卡里尔开车从他位于盐湖城的家中出发，向北向东行驶了2000英里，直到到达芝加哥，与人们谈论即将到来的战争。如果美国人的性格中既有深刻的怀疑态度，又有大胆的爱国主义，那么他在同一个人身上往往都发现了这两种倾向。
Hate is a complex emotion, hard to understand. There's the hate in other people, and there's the hate inside, hiding at the bottom of my heart, both shown at once by the building's collapsing. The best advice I heard was from a friend, who said that thinking was out of the question for a while. But it's hard not to think. And after 10 days, I got in my truck and drove north towards Yellowstone. The leaves would be changing, and the air might bite. The air is clear, and light as sharp as a diamond.
仇恨是一种复杂的情感，很难理解。有别人的仇恨，也有内心深处的仇恨，隐藏在我心的底部，都被建筑物倒塌瞬间所展现出来。我听到的最好的建议来自一个朋友，他说思考暂时是不可能的。但很难不去想。10天后，我开着卡车向北驶向黄石公园。树叶会变色，空气可能会有寒意。空气清新，光线像钻石一样锐利。
170 miles, I stopped in Afton, Wyoming in the Star Valley, home of Olympic gold medal wrestler, goofy Rulon Gardner. It was evening, getting dark, and I saw lights from a playing field, and stopped to watch a soccer game and talk to some people in bleachers.
170英里，我在怀俄明州星谷的阿夫顿停了下来，那是奥运会金牌摔跤手、笨拙的鲁隆·加德纳的家。那是傍晚，天黑了，我看到操场上的灯光，停下来看一场足球赛并和看台上的一些人交谈。
OK, I'm Shane Ogenson. We're in Star Valley, Wyoming. It's kind of a small rural area. Most of the economy is based on dairy farming and whatnot.
好的，我是谢恩·奥根森。我们在怀俄明州星谷。这是一个偏小的农村地区。大多数经济基础是奶牛养殖之类的。
How old are you?
你多大了？
I'm 18.
我18岁。
So the question I'm asking everybody is, are you ready to go to war?
所以我问所有人的问题是，你准备好去打仗了吗？
I think it's scary. And I'm draftable, so if it does turn into something that's major or something, then I could be shipped off to someplace I don't want to go and doing something that I don't really want to do.
我觉得这很可怕。而且我可以被征召入伍，所以如果它演变成某种重大事件，那么我可能会被派到某个我不想去的地方，做一些我真的不想做的事。
So are you ready to go to war? No, you're not.
所以你准备好去打仗了吗？不，你没有。
If my country needs me, I'll go. I think it's my responsibility as an America. If my country needs me, I'll go and I'll die for my country, and I'll be proud of it. But I'm not sure if I support the exact cause of why we'd be fighting this war. I mean, I think the perpetrators should be punished, but I'm not sure if going to war is going to solve that, especially when you don't have any specific real enemy to be going after.
如果我的国家需要我，我会去的。我认为这是作为美国人的责任。如果我的国家需要我，我会去，我会为我的国家而死，我会为此感到自豪。但我不知道我是否支持我们打这场战争的确切理由。我的意思是，我认为肇事者应该受到惩罚，但我不知道去打仗是否能解决这个问题，特别是当你没有任何特定的真正敌人可以去追捕的时候。
My name is Jenny Hanson, and we're in Afton, Wyoming at my 15 year old's soccer game. Am I ready to go to war? I believe that if it's going to make the world a safer place to live, if you can eliminate terrorism, yeah, I would support it. Yeah, I mean, I have five sons, and it's scary to even think about going to work, but that's the price of freedom.
我叫珍妮·汉森，我们在怀俄明州阿夫顿参加我15岁孩子的足球比赛。我准备好去打仗了吗？我相信，如果它能让世界变得更安全，如果我们能消除恐怖主义，是的，我会支持它。是的，我的意思是，我有五个儿子，想到要去工作都很可怕，但这就是自由的代价。
Even if it meant your own sons going to war?
即使这意味着你自己的儿子去打仗？
Yeah, even if it meant my own sons. That's scary, but all the other mothers would have to sacrifice their sons too. And there'll be those that will run, but that's their choice. But to me, the price of freedom is through sacrifice.
是的，即使这意味着我自己的儿子。那很可怕，但所有其他母亲也必须牺牲她们的儿子。总会有一些人会逃跑，但那是她们的选择。但对我来说，自由的代价是通过牺牲来实现的。
I drove through one of the southern entrances to Yellowstone Park at midnight. I pulled off the road on some kind of dirt loop and slept, waking up in the early morning looking straight at Mt. Moran, the Teton with a white tongue of snow, a [UNINTELLIGIBLE] down the center of the eastern face. In an hour, I was at the northern end of Yellowstone Lake, the water clear and quiet, the rocks along the shore palm sized, round and dark, perfect for throwing, not for skipping, but at another man's head.
我在午夜开车穿过黄石公园的南入口之一。我把车停在某种泥土环路上睡觉，清晨醒来时直视莫兰山，蒂顿山脉上有一条白色的积雪舌头，穿过东坡的中心。一小时后，我到了黄石湖的北端，水清澈安静，岸边的岩石手掌大小，圆而黑，非常适合投掷，不是用来打水漂的，而是用来扔向另一个人的头。
I follow the Yellowstone River to Mammoth Hot Springs, out of the park, and down Paradise Valley to Deep Creek, where I stopped to talk to Doug Peacock.
我沿着黄石河走到猛犸温泉，出了公园，沿着天堂谷下到深溪，我在那里停下来和道格·皮科克交谈。
My name is Doug Peacock, and we're sitting in my front yard, which is an old farmhouse with a huge cottonwood tree that's dying, and we're in the shade of the cottonwood right now. If I learned anything from Vietnam, it's just that there was no enlightenment at homicide. And what finally sent me over the edge was the Tet Offensive where my little A-Camp-- I was a Green Beret medic-- and my little A-Camp, the Viet Cong drove a couple hundred civilians across the river, and our A-Camp called in gunships on them. And about 180 women and children were killed and wounded. And I was the only medic there, and I spent my last two weeks in Vietnam splicing back together bodies.
我叫道格·皮科克，我们正坐在我的前院，那是一个旧农舍，有一棵巨大的正在枯死的棉白杨树，我们现在就在棉白杨树的阴凉处。如果说我从越南战争中学到了什么，那就是杀人没有任何启蒙。最终让我崩溃的是春节攻势，当时我的小A营——我是绿色贝雷帽医生——我的小A营，越共把几百名平民赶过河，我们的A营在他们身上召来了炮艇。大约180名妇女和儿童被杀伤。我是那里唯一的医生，我最后两周在越南都是在拼接尸体。
And that pushed me over the edge. And I just realized that either I was going to have to live the rest of my life with an eye for an eye notion, or to retain any trace of humanity, I was going to have to really suffer with this. The enemy is within, and it's within all of us. And I think the greatest thing we could do, having been the victim, finally we've been the victim, is to realize that our own hands are not that clean at all. I think the most courageous thing we could do is not strike back at all, not strike back. No eye for an eye. Defeat hate, and you can't do that by war and violence, you've got to do it by love. And you get there, I think, by looking at the sufferings of others, even the ones we don't like out there.
那把我推向了边缘。我意识到要么我余生必须带着以眼还眼的观念生活，要么为了保留任何一丝人性，我必须真正为此受苦。敌人就在内部，它就在我们所有人心中。我认为我们作为受害者，最终我们已经成为了受害者，能做的最伟大的事情就是意识到我们自己的手根本没有那么干净。我认为我们能做的最勇敢的事情是根本不反击，不反击。没有以眼还眼。战胜仇恨，你不能通过战争和暴力做到这一点，你必须通过爱来做到这一点。我想，你通过观察他人的痛苦到达那里，即使是我们不喜欢的人。
I remembered reading in Blackout Speaks , or maybe Great Plains by Ian Frazier that Crazy Horse, when he was killed, was trying to get back to the Powder River on the Northwest side of the Black Hills. But he was stabbed, held by a friend and bayoneted in the back at Fort Robinson, way on the other side of the mountains. I asked Peacock how to get to the Powder River, and he got out a map and showed me. He said, on your way, go through Plenty Coups and stop at the museum. Plenty Coups was a Crow chief who sided with the US cavalry against their traditional enemies, the Sioux and the Cheyenne.
我记得在伊恩·弗雷泽的《黑喉部落》或《大平原》中读到过，疯马在被杀时正试图回到黑山西北侧的粉河。但他被刺伤了，被一个朋友抓住，并在罗宾逊堡被刺刀刺中后背，在山的那一边。我问皮科克怎么去粉河，他拿出一张地图给我看。他说，在路上，经过“丰功伟绩”，停在博物馆。丰功伟绩是一位克劳族酋长，他站在美国骑兵一边，对抗他们传统的敌人苏族和夏延族。
I found the museum 150 miles to the east, 40 miles down a dirt road, and when I walked in, the woman at the desk said, are you lost? Which made me laugh hard like an idiot, and I said, I wish. Her name was Bernadette Smith.
我在东边150英里处找到了博物馆，沿着一条泥路走了40英里，当我走进去时，前台的女人说：“你迷路了吗？”这让我像个白痴一样大笑，我说：“我希望能。”她的名字是伯纳黛特·史密斯。
Are you ready to go to war?
你准备好去打仗了吗？
No, I'm not ready to go to war. But we have to protect our citizens, so if war is inevitable, then I will support it.
不，我还没准备好去打仗。但我们必须保护我们的公民，所以如果战争不可避免，那么我会支持它。
Do you have any relatives who might be going?
你有亲戚可能会去吗？
I have a-- oh, I shouldn't tell you this.
我有一个——哦，我不该告诉你这个。
That's all right, you don't have to.
没关系，你不必说。
My nephew is in Marine reserves, and he's in Bulgaria now. He's in a reconnaissance battalion. And he called-- he said the next time we heard from him would probably be through his Staff Sergeant.
我的侄子是海军陆战队预备役，他现在在保加利亚。他在一个侦察营。他打过电话——他说下次我们听到他的消息可能就是通过他的上士了。
She's kind of hard to understand because she's crying, but she's saying that her nephew, whom she raised as a son, called and said goodbye. That the next call she'd get would be from a Staff Sergeant, saying he'd been killed.
因为她在哭，很难听懂她在说什么，但她在说她的侄子，她像儿子一样抚养长大的，打电话说再见。她接到的下一个电话将是上士打来的，说他已经阵亡了。
He's a paratrooper, and he's probably the first to go in when you go in searching for somebody. And pride themselves on--.
他是一名伞兵，当你去搜寻某人时，他可能是第一个进去的。并且以——为荣。
How do you feel about that?
你对此有何感想？
I personally don't like it, but kids are raised. They have their dreams, they want to be macho, they want to save their country. He's a Crow Indian, and he wants to help save the tribe and promote peace, so what can you do but support him? That's not what you raised him for, but if that's one of their goals, you just have to accept it.
我个人不喜欢它，但孩子们是被养大的。他们有梦想，想变得大男子主义，想拯救他们的国家。他是克劳印第安人，他想帮助拯救部落并促进和平，所以除了支持他，你能做什么？这不是你养他的目的，但如果这是他们的目标之一，你只能接受它。
The battlefield of the Little Big Horn is 60 miles east of the Plenty Coups Museum, still in Montana. It looks just like it does in the movies, a pathetic knob on a grass prairie, a lonely place to be slaughtered. There are crosses marking where Custer and his brother fell, along with all of his men, more than 260, mostly immigrants. They ran out of bullets and were scalped. There's a museum there as well, and inside there are three of Custer's uniforms. He was a small man, I'm guessing no bigger than 5'4" and 130 pounds.
小巨角战场在“丰功伟绩”博物馆以东60英里处，仍在蒙大拿州。它看起来就像电影里的一样，大草原上的一个小土丘，一个被屠杀的孤独地方。有十字架标记着卡斯特和他的兄弟倒下的地方，连同他所有的手下，260多人，大多是移民。他们子弹打光了，被剥了头皮。那里也有一个博物馆，里面有卡斯特的三套制服。他是个小个子，我猜不比5英尺4英寸、130磅大。
My name is Bill Bennett. We're traveling through Custer National Park right now. There's a national cemetery here. The cemetery houses veterans of clear back to Spanish American War, clear up to the Korean War. Let's pray and hope that we don't have any from the Taliban War that may eventually be buried here. I lived in Iran for two and a half years when the Afghan coup in 1978 came.
我叫比尔·贝内特。我们现在正穿过卡斯特国家公园。这里有一个国家公墓。公墓里安葬着从美西战争一直到朝鲜战争的退伍军人。让我们祈祷并希望不要有任何可能最终埋葬在这里的塔利班战争阵亡者。1978年阿富汗政变时，我在伊朗住了两年半。
Why were you over there in Iran at that point?
那时候你为什么在伊朗？
I was a maintenance adviser to the Iranian Air Force when they were attempting to get their Air Force up to comparable Air Force to the United States government on their F-16s and F-4s, and some of those things back in the late '70s. And I've driven across Afghanistan, so I got a pretty good feel for the country and the mountains. And I think for them to put troops on the grounds in there, with that type of terrain and everything, is going to be disastrous.
当伊朗空军试图在70年代末通过F-16和F-4战机让他们的空军达到可与美国政府比肩的水平时，我是他们的维修顾问。我开车穿过阿富汗，所以我对这个国家和山脉有相当好的了解。我认为他们如果把地面部队派进去，以那种地形和一切，将是灾难性的。
The terrain in the northern part there is very, very mountainous, And in the desert it's just high brush. And to give you an example, we were driving a Chevrolet Blazer across there, and another couple was with us. We drive across the flat plain, and just nothing but brush and sand as far as the eye could see. We'd stop and pull off the road and put the back door of the Blazer down and get some drinks and some sandwiches or something out, and in 10 minutes, there'd be two or three men standing around us. And they had these sandy colored leather coverings on, and you couldn't see them. You'd never ever see them out in the desert.
北部的地形非常非常多山，而在沙漠里只是高草丛。举个例子，我们开着雪佛兰开拓者穿过那里，还有另一对夫妇和我们在一起。我们穿过平坦的平原，除了草丛和沙子，视线所及空无一物。我们停下来把车停在路边，放下开拓者的后门，拿出一些饮料和三明治什么的，在10分钟内，会有两三个人站在我们周围。他们穿着沙色的皮革覆盖物，你看不到他们。你永远在沙漠里看不到他们。
And they were curious enough that when we stopped, they'd come up. They wouldn't take any water, they wouldn't take anything. How they lived out there, I don't have any idea. But as proven by the Russians being in there, that's why they whipped the Russians, because you just don't see them.
他们很好奇，当我们停下来时，他们会走过来。他们不喝水，什么也不要。我不知道他们怎么在那种地方生活。但正如俄国人进入那里所证明的，这就是为什么他们打败了俄国人，因为你就是看不到他们。
So if you were called-- I realize you are past that age, but if you were of age and you were called now, would you go?
所以如果你被征召——我意识到你已经过了那个年龄，但如果你到了年龄而且现在被征召，你会去吗？
Of course I would, you betcha. Every time they play the National Anthem, I get a tear in my eye. I'm as true an American as you'll ever find.
当然我会去，你打赌吧。每次他们奏国歌，我的眼里都会流下眼泪。我是你见过的最忠诚的美国人。
Pine Ridge Reservation for the Oglala Lakota is on the High Plains, on the eastern side of the Black Hills, South Dakota. Wounded Knee is there, the site of the 1890 massacre of 300 men, women, and children wiped out for ghost dancing. The town of Pine Ridge has a distinct Third World feel to it. One taco stand, a gas station run out of a mobile home, a grocery store with sale prices painted on butcher paper and stapled to the walls outside, some coming apart in the wind and blowing around the parking lot.
奥格拉拉拉科塔族的松树岭保留地位于黑山东侧、南达科他州的高原上。伤膝河在那里，1890年因幽灵舞而被消灭的300名男子、妇女和儿童的大屠杀地点。松树岭镇有一种明显的第三世界感觉。一个塔可饼摊，一个用移动房屋经营的加油站，一家杂货店，特价贴在屠夫纸上并用订书机钉在墙外，有些在风中脱落，在停车场周围飘荡。
I was standing next my truck in the parking lot, drinking a Pepsi, and there were two men in a beat up Monte Carlo next to me. The one in the passenger seat called over. Hey, hey, my friend wants to see your badge. Somehow I got them to agree to an interview.
我站在停车场我的卡车旁边喝百事可乐，旁边有一辆破旧的蒙特卡洛车，里面有两个男人。副驾驶座位上的人喊道：“嘿，嘿，我的朋友想看你的徽章。”不知怎么的，我让他们同意接受采访。
Hello. My name is George Rester. I'm 37 seven years old. I am from Wounded Knee, South Dakota.
你好。我叫乔治·雷斯特。我37岁。我来自南达科他州伤膝河。
So the question I've been asking everybody is, are you ready to go to war?
所以我问所有人的问题是，你准备好去打仗了吗？
Of course. Oglala Lakota are always warriors. We won't lay down. It's going to happen. No fear, we'll do it.
当然。奥格拉拉拉科塔人永远是战士。我们不会躺下。它会发生的。没有恐惧，我们会做到的。
Would you personally sign up?
你会亲自报名吗？
Well, I've been to Panama, the Gulf. I will do it again.
嗯，我去过巴拿马，去过海湾。我会再做一次。
You're a veteran?
你是退伍军人？
Yeah.
是的。
So what do you think about the war on terrorism. How do you feel about it?
那么你对反恐战争有什么看法？你对此有什么感觉？
It's a senseless cause. An enemy you can reach and touch and kill. But this one, faceless.
这是一个毫无意义的事业。一个你可以接触、触摸并杀死的敌人。但这个，没有脸。
Why are you so willing to support it, if it's a war like that?
如果是一场那样的战争，你为什么这么愿意支持它？
Because of the flag. My dad served in World War I, World War II. Patriotism, that's what it is.
因为国旗。我父亲参加过第一次世界大战，第二次世界大战。爱国主义，就是这样。
But you're willing to go because of the warrior tradition?
但你愿意去是因为战士传统？
Yeah, of course.
是的，当然。
It's the idea of fighting and--
这是关于战斗和——的理念
It's the adrenaline flow of reaching inside another person's body and pulling their heart out when it's sill beating, that's what it is.
这是当别人的心脏还在跳动时，伸进他的身体并把它掏出来的肾上腺素流动，就是这样。
Driving across South Dakota, I can't remember it. The Missouri was dammed into a reservoir, I do remember that. Maybe I drove most of it at night. I know I woke up in southern Minnesota, found a town, and stopped at a restaurant that opened early.
开车穿过南达科他州，我不记得了。密苏里河被筑坝变成了一个水库，我记得那个。也许我大部分时间是在晚上开的。我知道我在明尼苏达州南部醒来，找到了一个镇，在一家早开的餐厅停了下来。
Chuck Murphy from Blue Earth, Minnesota. We're in a restaurant called Hamilton's. We meet down here on Sunday morning, we call it our Sunday School. We still all go to church, but it's just something we do. We get together.
查克·墨菲来自明尼苏达州蓝土。我们在一家叫汉密尔顿的餐厅。我们周日上午在这里见面，我们称之为我们的“主日学”。我们仍然都去教堂，但这只是我们做的事情。我们聚在一起。
So the question I've been asking everybody is, are you ready to go to war?
所以我问所有人的问题是，你准备好去打仗了吗？
I think we should go to war.
我认为我们应该去打仗。
How come? So how about you sir?
为什么？那么你呢，先生？
Well, I don't know, it's about-- I think it is really going to be good for this country. It's going to bring everybody together, it is. Because I think what had happened before is we started going in our own separate directions. People were doing this and doing that, and this has just plain brought the country back together. And I think it's going to be a whole different country from now on.
嗯，我不知道，这是关于——我认为这真的会对这个国家有好处。它会把所有人聚在一起，确实。因为我认为以前发生的事情是我们开始向各自不同的方向发展。人们做这个做那个，而这件事简直把这个国家重新聚在了一起。我认为从现在开始它将是一个完全不同的国家。
Driving around, listening to talk radio, it didn't seem to me like the country was becoming more united.
开车四处转，听谈话广播，在我看来，国家并没有变得更加团结。
Frankly I'm shocked at what I'm hearing from you, I can't believe that you're so un-American. [INTERPOSING VOICES] And you're attacking-- oh, free speech, my foot. [INTERPOSING VOICES] I'm starting to get livid at your attacks on the United States of America and this president.
坦率地说，听到你的话我感到震惊，我不敢相信你竟然如此不爱国。[干扰的声音] 你们在攻击——哦，言论自由，去你的。[干扰的声音] 对于你们攻击美利坚合众国和这位总统，我开始感到火大。
I'm not attacking this country.
我没有攻击这个国家。
You have been.
你一直都在。
I support this country. I don't know why you have me on.
我支持这个国家。我不知道你为什么让我上节目。
I don't either. You're right, that's the first smart thing you've said. Get her off the phone. Goodbye. 1-800-655-MIKE, I don't know why I had her on either. You know, there's no room for that kind of voice right now in America. We don't need her. Go over to Afghanistan and--
我也不知道。你是对的，这是你说的第一句聪明话。让她下线。再见。1-800-655-MIKE，我也不知道为什么让她上节目。你知道，现在美国没有那种声音的容身之处。我们不需要她。去阿富汗然后——
I'm Ryan Walden, and I'm a biologist here at Northeastern Iowa. And this is a hawk watch weekend, and I do educational programs with birds of prey.
我是瑞安·沃尔登，我是爱荷华州东北部的生物学家。这是鹰类观察周末，我做关于猛禽的教育项目。
Has your life changed since the Tuesday attack?
自周二袭击以来，你的生活改变了吗？
Yes, as a matter of fact it has, and in a very strange way. One of the items that I talk about in the program, and I've done my program since 1970, is that the call of the barn owl sounds like a hysterically screaming woman. No one has ever commented on that before, and yet yesterday, there were two complaints registered that I had said that.
是的，事实上确实改变了，而且是以一种非常奇怪的方式。我在项目中谈论的项目之一，而且我从1970年就开始做我的项目了，是仓鸮的叫声听起来像歇斯底里的尖叫女人。以前从来没有人评论过这一点，然而昨天，有两项投诉登记说我说了那话。
Can you understand that?
你能理解吗？
I think that it's absolutely totally and completely ridiculous. Will I change? Yes, simply because I am paid to be here, and my job is to educate people are not to offend them. But I think that the American people should stop whining about Mickey Mouse things such as that, and get some handle on what is really important.
我认为这绝对是彻底和完全荒谬的。我会改变吗？是的，仅仅因为我拿了报酬来到这里，我的工作是教育人们，而不是冒犯他们。但我认为美国人民应该停止抱怨像米老鼠那样的事情，并对什么是真正重要的有所了解。
The wind had been blowing hard from the north, coming down from Canada, and it clouded up and started to rain. I crossed the Mississippi at Prairie du Chien, Prairie of Dog, Wisconsin, headed for Madison through farm country, rolling fields of corn, waves of corn, big silos and barns. I saw two Amish boys walking down the road, and I pulled into a driveway and waited for them to come up to me.
风一直在从北方强劲地吹来，从加拿大吹下来，天阴了开始下雨。我穿过普雷里德欣的密西西比河，威斯康星州的狗草原，穿过农田向麦迪逊进发，滚动的玉米地，玉米波浪，巨大的筒仓和谷仓。我看到两个阿米什男孩走在路上，我把车开进一条车道，等着他们走过来。
Come up here a little closer.
走近点。
Do we have to do this now? I mean, our religion is-- we'd just as well stay away from it if we can, but you got to have our advice?
我们现在必须这样做吗？我的意思是，我们的宗教是——如果我们能避开它，我们宁愿避开它，但你一定要我们的建议吗？
I don't have to have your advice. I'm asking you for it.
我不一定要你的建议。我在问你要它。
Well, we will consciously object to fighting with firearms. All we know is what the neighbors are saying. We have no electricity. We get a weekly newspaper, but we do not know what's going on out there.
好吧，我们将有意识地反对用枪支战斗。我们所知道的只是邻居们在说的。我们没有电。我们有一份周报，但我们不知道外面在发生什么。
What have you heard?
你听到了什么？
Well, we've heard that the planes crashed in New york. We've heard there were a lot of people lost. We pray for you in our churches, but we are not involved in your-- we are not involved in this.
嗯，我们听说飞机在纽约坠毁了。我们听说很多人失去了生命。我们在教堂里为你祈祷，但我们不参与你们的——我们不参与这件事。
Now I'm in Chicago, staying at the Hotel InterContinental on the 25th floor. From my window, I can look across and see the flying buttresses on top of the Tribune Building, a building with stones mortared into its base from battlefields, monuments, and temples from around the world. One from the Great Wall of China, one from the Coliseum in Rome. Stones from the Islands of Corregidor and Guam, from Pearl Harbor, one from the Little Big Horn in Yellowstone Park. Even a rock from Indian Joe's Cave along the Mississippi River, and a section of a California Redwood.
现在我在芝加哥，住在25楼的洲际酒店。从我的窗户看过去，可以看到论坛报大厦顶部的飞扶壁，这是一座建筑物，底部用来自世界各地战场、纪念碑和寺庙的石头砌成。一块来自中国长城，一块来自罗马斗兽场。来自科雷希多岛和关岛的石头，来自珍珠港，一块来自黄石公园的小巨角战场。甚至还有一块来自密西西比河沿岸印第安乔洞穴的石头，以及加州红木的一部分。
It's late at night. There's one car on Grand Avenue all the way to Navy Pier, reaching out into Lake Michigan. A drunk crossing the street and stumbling at the curb, falling down on the sidewalk and getting up, staggering towards home. It's a beautiful night, moon half full. I keep forgetting. I keep forgetting watching the buildings come down. But they did come down, and now we're going to war. More limbs blown off, guts exploded open, eyes gouged out and heads chopped off.
夜深了。格兰德大道上有一辆车一直开到海军码头，伸入密歇根湖。一个醉汉穿过街道，在路边绊倒，倒在人行道上又站起来，摇摇晃晃地向家走去。这是一个美丽的夜晚，月亮半圆。我一直在忘记。我一直在忘记看着建筑物倒塌。但它们确实倒塌了，现在我们要去打仗了。更多的四肢被炸飞，内脏被炸开，眼睛被挖出，脑袋被砍掉。
I remember listening to the beginning of the Bears Viking game driving into town on Sunday. I realize that you shouldn't go into a fight thinking you might lose or thinking you might win, or wondering whether what you're doing is right or wrong. The best advice is to not think at all.
我记得周日开车进城时听熊队和维京队的比赛。我意识到你不应该带着你可能会输或者可能会赢的想法，或者怀疑你所做的事情是对还是错的想法去打仗。最好的建议是根本不要思考。
Scott Carrier.
斯科特·卡里尔。
Well, a huge big thanks today to Jerome McDonald and Andrea Wenzel of WBEZ's program World View . Also thanks to Joe Richmond, Allison True, Carrie Maninetti, John Dorner, John Connors, Barry Glass, and Mike Black at WEOS in Geneva, New York. Jason Bitner played our folk cover of the song War. Scott Carrier's story was supported by hearingvoices.com, with funds provided by the Corporation For Public Broadcasting. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
今天非常感谢WBEZ节目《全球视野》的杰罗姆·麦克唐纳和安德里亚·温泽尔。还要感谢乔·里士满、艾莉森·特鲁、嘉莉·马尼内蒂、约翰·多纳、约翰·康纳斯、巴里·格拉斯和纽约州日内瓦WEOS的迈克·布莱克。杰森·比特纳演奏了我们民谣版的歌曲《战争》。斯科特·卡里尔的故事由hearingvoices.com提供支持，资金由公共广播公司提供。本节目由公共广播国际电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who in these hard times is trying not to say anything offensive.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他在这些艰难时期正试图不说什么冒犯人的话。
Simply because I am paid to be here, and my job is to educate people and not to offend them.
仅仅因为我拿了报酬来到这里，我的工作是教育人们，而不是冒犯他们。
That's right. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
没错。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际电台。